Pro Football Hall of Fame head coach and
individual Tony Dungy good to see you
sir
how are you it's good to be with look
forward to chatting about this book that
you and your wife Lauren put together
New York Times bestselling author we
chose you about adoption you and Lauren
have seven adopted children so obviously
this book means a lot to you and I look
forward to chatting about this with you
guys shortly but I do want to talk some
football but and before all that talking
about what I mentioned in the first
segment of the show about what Steve
Kerr is currently doing with the Golden
State Warriors five straight finals and
what it takes to keep the the same rock
up the same Hill despite the
championships every single year I'd love
to get your thoughts on all that it is
amazing number one to do that that
consistently and and be at that level
and then number two to have that many
star players and people think okay well
that's the easy part he's got it easy
he's got the best players in the world
but keeping everybody motivated keeping
everybody sharp and with every other
team in the league coming after you I
think what he's done has really been
amazing
well what challenges does it take to
keep guys you have to walk that fine
line of continuing to motivate and push
buttons and you push these buttons for
five or six years or some of these guys
given them enough leeway and enough rope
to be their their own guys
but then tightening everything down when
you need to and it's it's not easy I can
tell you that and I think he's done a
masterful job I've watched them you know
three times down 15 down 17 and just
knowing when to spark and when to say
hey we're gonna be okay he's done a
great job well cuz I know people will
say about Steve Kerr what they said
about Phil Jackson just roll the
basketballs out it and they said many
people would say you all you got to do
is roll the football out for Payton and
Edgerrin and Marvin and Reggie Wayne and
off you go and I wonder what what did
you think when you ever you heard
something well you know it's funny this
time you're in football we always think
well it's just a matter of
being talent together Cleveland's gonna
be in the Super Bowl because of all this
talent they're getting right but that's
not what builds championship teams it's
chemistry it's working together it's
getting people to buy into the winning
is the most important thing all the
talent in the world doesn't win for you
you've got to put it together and get
guys on the same page that that's what
coaching is Chuck Noll was my coach in
Pittsburgh four Super Bowls in six years
never one coach of the year because
everybody says oh you've got all that
talent but focusing the talent and
keeping them together is the biggest
challenge in sports and I think Steve
Kerr has done it really well do you know
him do you that I've gotten to meet
Steve my boys are Warriors fans so of
course see them when they come come East
yeah everybody wants to be Steph Curry
but I really have appreciated just how
he's done things and III admire him so
when you say Tony Dungy here in the Rich
Eisen show that you got to know that
fine line about pushing buttons
certainly since if your voice has
already been heard by the guy whose
buttons you're pushing over and over
again is a challenge did you ever have
to do that with Peyton like what button
buttons your push with him Tony for him
it was slowing people slowing him down
you know he'd have 20 new things that
he'd want to do and we can do this and
this would be great against this team
and say yeah but the other 43 guys might
not be able to go at that quicker level
so what are the real what are the eight
things that we can do and change and
tweak a little bit that'll be good for
us and you know he was great he's a
great teammate he was great to coach
because all the things you talked about
as a head coach this is what we need to
be we need to be unselfish we need to be
hard-working we need to be good
teammates we need to prepare he was
demonstrating that so it made it easy
but it's still getting everybody focused
and everybody on the same page well I
mean nobody ever likes to have somebody
speak on behalf of somebody and
certainly it might make you
uncomfortable to do it for Peyton but
I'll ask it anyway the conversation
being had in New York City that maybe
the Jets reach out to have him at
general managers that sound like
something people would want to do he
would be awesome and I've talked to him
a little bit and you know he talked
about doing TV for a while I think there
is something that intrigues him about
putting a team together and being part
of that in building a winner and he's
certainly if he does do it he'll go into
it a hundred miles an hour and he'll be
excellent at it why do you think he'll
be excellent
he knows what it takes to win he knows
how to bring people together and he
likes challenges so I think he'd be
great but one of the rare things that
I've seen is an all-time great you just
even said it right there Tony is that
you got to slow him down you had a it
wasn't a button you were pushing it
sounded more like a switch you got to
turn off with him because all-time
greats goats operate at a different
plane not only mentally but the drive
inside that not everybody has it that's
why the Hall of Fame isn't filled with
thousands people that's why there's only
like 300 or so colleagues of yours in
that Hall so being able to to put that
aside and see in people what maybe they
don't have what a team together exactly
tough I was in Indiana when Larry Bird
was there and it was tough for Larry
because he was used to playing at a
certain level to working hard and when
everybody on all 13 of those guys didn't
come in with the same Drive that he was
used to saying it was difficult for him
and that sometimes the great ones it can
be tough to understand that not
everybody has that same hmm that they
have and they have to get it out of
right but people can evolve I guess Dion
as you know is become a terrific high
school coach okay and I remember in the
first few years of watching games with
him at the NFL Network when some guy did
which just did some dumb play on the
field he would scream cut him I wouldn't
cut him by the time he comes back on the
side and you were just scream at the
screen cut him and now he's got the
patience of a coach that has to grow on
you but what people didn't realize about
Deon you see all the flash and the flam
boy
sure he was a hard worker he has
dedicated he knew his craft and he it
was winning was important to him so he
had to temper that now especially with
the young young kids and grow into it a
little bit but I could see where he'd be
an excellent excellent coach with young
people well let's talk a little bit
about evolution as we move on into a
football chat with Tony Dungy Pro
Football Hall of Famer then Rob this
burger it sounds like a more you're
laughing over there
you like that segue anybody he's talking
about more he seems leave evolved and
and this is what he had to say locally
in Pittsburgh on Monday in regards to a
lot of the comments the
passive-aggressive comments that he
threw in the direction of many teammates
including a Antonio Brown who has no
longer a Pittsburgh address in many ways
because of it well you know I'll start
with saying you're right a B made me you
know who I am I mean he was the greatest
Hydra C or they have ever played with
and and the things that he did in this
league and that we did together you know
are amongst the best of all time and you
you're right there was there was some
great things and then all of a sudden it
just kind of it disappeared and I'm not
I'm not really sure where it went we
always always work through it you know
we always came out the other side
smiling and and hugged it out and
enjoyed it and moved on and you know
this this time I really don't know he
also said he was genuinely sorry for
some of the comments that he said in the
comments that he made in and of
themselves are comments that aren't
happen all the time but they don't get
said on a radio show I mean those kind
of things on the sidelines on the
practice field in the locker room it
happened all the time but me as a head
coach or Ben Roethlisberger as a
quarterback there are some things that
you can't say to the general public
about your teammates you can't say it in
a forum like a radio show it just
doesn't come off that when I think
that's what happened you got to
soundbite number two because I think
that that might actually be a better one
to play right here go go for you know
it's a fine line to walk sometimes of of
giving information out giving some cool
things for the fans to be a
and maybe saying too much and and I know
that I took some heat and deservedly so
for some of the comments that I've made
on that show and especially towards him
and and I genuinely feel bad about that
and I'm sorry did I go too far after
that Denver game probably I mean that's
the thing about media and social media
and things like that is so you say you
know sorry only goes so far right you
can't take it back and and I wish I
could because if that's what ruined our
friendship and our relationship then I
truly am genuinely sorry about that
and then so how did that land in Oakland
do we have the deficit let's see the via
the two-word tweet Tony Dungy saw here
he goes to face Antonio Robb what was
Tomlin dealing with do you think you
know with a lot of personalities with
what every coach deals with and people
think it's easy and it's not because you
get high quality guys you get guys who
are driven you get guys who want to win
in precious situations and these are all
the things that you have to navigate and
finding a way to do that
and finding a way to give them enough
responsibility so they can be who they
are but also channeling in the right
direction it's a fine line to walk do
you get calls or texts from Tomlin I
talked to Mike occasionally yeah does he
ask for your advice or do you give it
not on things like that
Mike understands how to deal with his
team and the personalities that are
there Mike I think was 29 years old when
he came to me and in Tampa and he had
the maturity of a much older coach and
he you know had Ronde Barber and John
Lynch and this crew of veteran guys and
he he did it very well so those kind of
things I don't think he needs my advice
well I know if you're aware but last
year I think aged him 20 much much older
man tough year after last year but some
of the conversation coming out was that
he let too much go Tony where do you
stand on that sub
you know when you win then what you do
is seen as a plus and you do the same
thing the next year and you lose it's a
negative I heard that many times - oh
he's relaxed he's calm he's poised
that's why we're winning then you don't
win and well you you didn't drive them
enough you weren't tough enough
coach Noll used to say that you know
character flaws show up and they get
talked about when you lose don't change
who you are don't worry about that
winning covers a multitude of sins and
you mentioned or he was dealing with a
lot of personalities it seems like
they're they're gone now
levy on bail in New York or at least the
issue with levy on getting paid that
Tommen clearly had no control over
that's gone and Antonio Brown as we all
know is in Oakland I think do and it
seems like they're able to play the
nobody believes in this card that the
Steelers rarely have in their deck Tony
well it is a different year for them
because everybody you know the last five
or six years all we well look how much
talent they have look at this guy and
they've got a great running back and a
great receiver and a great quarterback
and now people are saying well what are
they gonna do without these guys and
sometimes that's you know that that's
motivating I think we've seen that with
the Warriors with Kevin being out
brackets this bench isn't very good
while the sudden the bench has to play
and they step up because they they're
forced to and many times circumstances
bring the best out of people
a couple more football questions for you
Tony Dungy before we bring your wife
Lauren out to talk about this this book
we chose you your latest book and a
best-selling combination for the New
York Times the the concept of every year
we see a team take a quantum leap and
make a huge run for the Super Bowl if
not win it all besides what Brady and
Belichick might have to say in the
equation which team do you think has the
best opportunity this year to do that
Tony it's really hard to say and I don't
like to say that at this time of year
because most people make that judgment
off of on paper yes oh they added this
person this person
Oakland's got Antonio Brown so now
they're gonna be better well we don't
know that but but what you get and those
teams that make that quantum leap are
the teams that come together and they
figure it out and they understand what
it takes we saw that from the Chargers
last year that all of a sudden what had
been in the mix for a couple of years
now comes together and they're ready so
what about a team that made the playoffs
last year but didn't make it as far or
they took a step forward last year I'll
throw a couple out I'm gonna just throw
out one go for it because I believe in
the guy so much in this Jacksonville
I believe in Nick Foles and I saw what
he did in Philadelphia and Jacksonville
has a lot of pieces in place and I think
Nick Foles can be a galvanizing force
that says you know what some of this
talent now coming together and working
together we're gonna be okay by the way
we've talked about that a little bit
here on this show if he goes to
Jacksonville now a lot of people will
just say because didn't work out towards
the end of the Chip Kelly era for him
wound up in st. Louis where as you know
many careers faltered with all due
respect to that organization back in st.
Louis so a lot of people think maybe
just maybe outside of the construct of
needing to do it towards the end of a
season in going and catching fire and
the playoffs is not sustainable over a
16 start season and the playoffs if
they're fortunate enough to make it if
he does actually go on continue some
form of a magic carpet ride that would
be one of the most amazing NFL stories
up there with and I'll say Warner Brady
that type of stuff like Foles has that
in front of him right now in
Jacksonville he does he's got a chance
to do it because they've got a good team
two years ago they're a couple plays
from the Superbowl and he's he's a
talented guy that what was the 27
touchdowns and two interceptions and one
sugar Kelly year right what he did down
the stretch with with the Eagles this
isn't a guy who was bereft of talent and
there's there's something about him I
we had the game that year the Super Bowl
and I had Philadelphia so I was I was
there for the championship game I was
there the week before doing interviews
and there was just something they
believed in him he felt they were gonna
get it done and and I came back I picked
the Eagles just because of that that
feeling and I think he's gonna bring
that same type of chemistry and the same
type of feeling to Jackson the last one
for you here too that your football
night in America colleague Peter King
dialed up a bunch of people I was one of
them about what would make a great
change in the NFL rule wise anything
like that a policy wise even from the
front office many were forwarded I
wonder what yours might be Tony mine
believe it or not would be and the
players wouldn't like it but it would be
no free agency really yes why
that's a draft people develop people I
don't know what you'd have to do with
the salary cap to expand that so guys
could get paid what they need but I'd
love to see guys get paid what they need
to get paid but stay on the team that
they're on I played with nine guys who
are in the Hall of Fame and it was great
and part of the reason they were so good
is they stayed in the same system they
knew each other they loved each other
they played together but to be able to
play with Joe green and Jack ham and
Jack Lambert for for ten years anybody
would benefit from that and fans would
benefit from it but but we don't see
that anymore yeah you're right that
would be very unpopular with the players
it would be but it would be cool for you
as a fan to say well you know we've got
these five great players and they're
gonna be here their whole career and I'm
gonna cheer for them and they're gonna
be my my heroes but we'd have to change
the rule in some way to make sure that
people's not left to their own do I said
that players would get paid what they
deserve yes so it would be a two-way
street
Hall of Famer Tony Dungy at Tony Dungy
on Twitter here on the Rich Eisen show
when we come back we'll be joined by
Lauren Dungy Tony's better half you know
mom is saying as well as better yeah
okay much better half and also half of
the best-selling author tandem of the
children's books the new children's book
series
called the the new book being called we
chose you right eye right here in front
of you a book about adoption family and
forever love that's when we come back
here on the Rich Eisen show don't you
dare move for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app